While each chart type might be slightly better for
slight differences in your data, and
what you're trying to communicate, in practice you can get by with only a few.
In navigating this jungle, I like to often start from first principles.
Chart types are simply a set of visual encodings applied to data types, and
combined with some relationship between those data.
For example, a scatterplot is an x coordinate and y coordinate with a shape,
in this case a circle as applied to two continuous variables,
continuous being their data type, in which the y value is dependent on
the x value, which corresponds to the relationship between them.
And combining all three of these things.
You get the chart type of a scatter plot.
As you can imagine, there are quite a few combinations of these three sets.
A set of the Visual Encodings possible, a set of Data Types possible,
a set of Relationships between your data types.
I think this flow chart does a fairly good job of categorizing the different
chart types by utility.
But I'll also add that I think a few are missing.
And I do have a few qualms about how Andrew chooses his branches about which
chart to use given which situation.
When choosing a chart type, I usually either start with the type and
dimension of my data, or
what relationships I'm trying to convey between my different columns.
For example, I might ask myself, how many dimensions do I have?
One dimension, two dimension, three dimensions.
And what type is each?
Continuous, categorical.
Am I trying to compare two variables,
am I trying to show how one variable is distributed?
Let's take that last question as a starting point.
Let's say I have one dimensional data that I'm
trying to see the distribution of.
I would use either a histogram for
continuous data, and I might possibly want to bin it.
Or a bar chart for categorical data, if I might have
some discrete values along the x axis that don't have any intrinsic order.
If I want to show a comparison of distributions, I'll use either a box plot, or
small multiples.
As they represent distributions of multiple variables,
side by side with each other.
We'll get into what each of these looks like in just a second.
But I want to mention them as you were talking about chart types to
represent distributions of data types and variables.
To represent a correlation between two variables where the y variable is
dependent on the x variable, a scatter plot is the most effective way and
the most commonly known.
A scatter plot can be generalized to a bubble chart [INAUDIBLE] Additional
dimension in visual encoding to represent, in this case the bubble chart
uses size of each of it's circles to represent a third variable.
A subtlety of the scatter plot, that the x variable is usually assumed to
be independent and uncorrelated with the other x values.
What does this mean exactly?
Well let's consider time series data.
When dealing with time, every data point is implicitly dependant on all
the data points that came earlier in time before it.
In this situation.
We want to use a line chart or
a multiple line chart to represent time series data.
That one has intrinsic order.
And two has data points that are dependent on what came before them.
With line charts the fact that every point is connected.
Shows a trend in your data and
implies that every data point does have this inherent connection between them.